[Music]
welcome to the program and we begin with
the situation in eastern Ukraine right
now where the head of Russia's Wagner
mercenary group is saying his forces
have taken full control of of the
besieged city of bakmut Evgeni pragosian
made the claim in a video
standing in front of a line of soldiers
holding Russian flags and Wagner banners
Bahamut has been the focus of the
longest and bloodiest battle of Russia's
war in Ukraine which is now approaching
its 16th month kiva's rejecting
pagosian's claim though they are saying
the situation the small eastern city is
critical Natasha Butler joins us live
now from Ukraine's Capital key so claims
and counter claims Natasha what are you
hearing about the situation in Bahamut
well look any claims made by the Wagner
boss are met with a lot of skepticism in
Ukraine because he has made various uh
claims over the past few months but what
we have heard from Ukrainian officials
is they are saying that Ukrainian forces
are still fighting uh in back much
Ukraine's Deputy defense minister says
the situation is indeed critical uh in
backwood the fighting has been intense
and heavy but Ukrainian forces are still
holding on to some critical uh
infrastructure so we have these two
claims the Ukrainian side the Wagner
bosses claims but what we do know of
course is backwood has been the scene of
some of the worst bitterest most Grim
fighting in this war it has become
something of a prize of Vladimir Putin
the Russian president would like to win
he wants to take back that has been the
focus for his Russian forces for many
months now as I said it has been been
extremely difficult though but it would
be a symbol in a way a Russian again and
Russia has not had many games in recent
months but it's also become a symbol for
ukrainians a symbol of Ukrainian
resistance president zielinski himself
talking about Fortress backmot a little
bit uh earlier this year
thank you very much from Kiev Natasha
Butler
we can also now hear from a journalist
who is based in Moscow this is Julia
chapalova who joins us now so Ukraine is
denying that the eastern city of Bahamut
has fallen under Russian control what
are you hearing there in Moscow
so basically regurgian did announce the
complete catch of bahmoud but it was not
the first time he made a statement like
that earlier he also reported several
times about the total capture of the
city but every time it was not true the
Russian authorities have not commented
on on his statements earlier the Russian
defense Ministry official representative
said that a Russian assault squads
continued liberating the western part of
the city but it is really very hard to
say what's happening on the ground right
now in his statement brigosian blamed a
defense minister shoigu and chief of
general staff Valeri garasimo for
turning the war into their own
entertainment and due to that five times
more Wagner Fighters died than pregosian
had expected and he also said that on
May the 25th the Wagner company would
leave the city because his Fighters
needed some rest and retraining so it's
a big ask now who's going to call the
city if the Ukrainian forces are still
there and not withdrawing and according
to pregosian the city will be handed
over to the Russian Ministry of Defense
and yet we have seen this tension
between provision and and the Kremlin as
you rightly say and uh you know
obviously he is claiming because in his
claiming that they have full control of
Batman this has been a very long and
Bloody War what what happens next then
for progression and his Wagner group
what is next for them
well probably you remember earlier on
progression was also threatening to lead
bahmoud on May the 10th together with
his Wagner group complaining about a
lack of Munitions and huge losses of his
Fighters and um but they stayed back
then and many analysts here were saying
that he naturally wanted to get out of
the game as he didn't want to be the
face of Russia's defeat in bahmoud if
things would go wrong especially after
Ukraine's Western Partners reported the
deliveries of 98 of promised Munitions
and weapons to Ukraine and according to
local sources I'm reading here pregosia
now seeks Safety and Security for his
own self and uh most likely he will
leave Russia soon and his most capable
and experienced fighters of the Wagner
group will allegedly be transferred to
Sudan thank you very much from Moscow
journalist Julia chapalova joining us